عندما نتحدث عن كل هذا اين هي السلطه
الفلسطينيه من كل ما يحدث نتحدث عن عمليه
نوعيه في سياق خاص عوده لسياسه الاغتيالات
هناك اصوات يمينيه تريد المزيد من الدماء
ومن العمليات ومن القتل اين السلطه
الفلسطينيه من كل ما يحدث
تاكيد يعني هناك حاله حرب مفتوحه على
الشعب الفلسطيني وعدوان متواصل على الشعب
الفلسطيني ليس فقط ما جرى قبل يومين في
غزه هذا استمرار لعامين متواصلين من
العدوان على شعبنا عدوان مفتوح في الضفه
يوميا في شهداء اكثر من 250 شهيد موجود
اليوم في الضفه خلال العام الماضي واليوم
ايضا هناك شهيدين وبالتالي هذا الحرب هو
حرب مفتوحه على كل الشعب الفلسطيني وعلى
كل مكونات الشعب الفلسطيني ضمن سياق
استهداف الوجود الفلسطيني اسرائيل
الموجوده اليوم مشكل المشكلين او اللاعبين
السياسيين في اسرائيل مثل مهم اسمه نعرف
انه هذا عنوان مهم للصراع مع الفلسطينيين
اليوم اللي هو عمليا اخذ اداره شؤون
الاداره المدنيه ايضا اللي اخذ موضوع قضيه
الامن القومي وقضيه الشرطه وقضيه النقب
وبمعنى ان من استلم الملف الفلسطيني وهم
اتباع الصهي الدينيه ممن يريدون ترحيل
وطرد الشعب الفلسطيني سواء في الغزه سواء
في الضفه وبالتالي هناك تناقض كبير مع اي
مشروع سواء كان مشروع مقاوم في غزه او
مشروع سياسي في الضفه او مشروع مقاوم في
الضفه الضفه منتفضه ومقاومه ومستمره
ولديها ايضا من الاساليب ما توجع اسرائيل
كثيرا اكثر من مناطق اخرى لان العمليه
الاحتكاك بكون متواصل اكثر حتى ان اذا
جينا نناقش قضيه خارطه الخطر على اسرائيل
هناك عنوان مهم اليوم بارز هو المحافظات
الجنوبيه او غزه وهناك ايضا الساحه
الشماليه لكن يقول اليوم في اسرائيل اليوم
ان الخطر الحقيقي يكمن في الداخل في الضفه
والداخل الفلسطيني وبالتالي عندما نرى
اطراف المعادله السياسيه الاسرائيليه
تحديدا هذه الرموز التي جاءت بعنوان الحسم
حسم الصراع على قاعده طرد الشعب الفلسطيني
وتصفيه وجود الشعب الفلسطيني ديموغرافيا
سياسيا وتفريغ اي مش السياسي سواء كان في
رام الله يتغزه هناك عند هذه الجماعات
التي تحكم اليوم مشروع يرون ان الفرصه
لديهم قد اكتملت من اجل تطبيق مشروع الحسم
على قاعده طرد الشعبي الفلسطيني يعني الذي
يدير هذا الملف الداخلي في العلاقه مع
الشعب الفلسطيني اليوم هو لديه افكار ثلاث
افكار واضحه يريد ان اول شرط هناك ثلاث
شروط الشرط الاول ان يسلم الشعب الفلسطيني
بان ليس له حقوق سياسيه في هذه الارض
والشرط الثاني عمليه فتح المجال لتهجير
الشعب الفلسطيني من خلال اغراءات ومغريات
وترهيب وترغيب والعمليه الثالثه او الشرط
الثالث ان كل من يرفض هذه الخيارات
بالتالي سيقتل ويحارب ويتم التعامل معهم
مثلما تم التعامل مع الكنعانيين ما يصرح
اسم